let's talk about the $1,200 checks that
people are increasingly anxious to
receive understandably Donald Trump's
Treasury secretary Stephen minuchin said
today said yesterday and today stimulus
checks are coming in three weeks
supposedly now the devil is into detail
so we're gonna go through those details
now the Senate remember has passed a two
trillion dollar stimulus bill the House
hasn't yet passed it they're expected to
pass it tomorrow Friday hopefully that
happens hopefully Trump signs it it's
been wildly delayed about ten days ago
this could have been done could have
been done closer to two weeks ago really
meaning if that had been done two weeks
ago we would now only be one week from
people starting to get the money instead
we are three weeks away but that's only
for roughly half the people the other
half are likely going to have to wait
three four or five additional weeks
meaning half of the folks who qualify
for the checks are likely two months
from receiving them meanwhile Trump
wants everything reopened in 18 days
April 12th he wants to let it rip and
have churches full now later I'm going
to tell you about the unemployment
numbers which have exploded biggest week
in new filing of unemployment in the
history of the United States the point
is people need cash here's Stephen
minuchin this morning on CNBC laying out
the timeline yes now is Treasury
Secretary Stephen ushion first mr.
secretary congratulations on the record
time you put this together quickly
versus 2007 2009 when will the checks be
in the mail well Jim first of all thanks
for having me back and I want to thank
the Senate for their swift action people
literally worked round the clock for
five days okay so I I apologize for
interrupting but so already everyone's
pretending this has happened so quickly
minuchin is thinking the Congress and
Trump's thinking is that the other thing
we knew this was coming six to eight
weeks ago they could have started the
framework for this at that point in time
it could have been done and signed 10
days ago
but regardless everybody Pat's each
other on the back we knew that we
expected that it's bogus let's continue
to the to the meat of this thing
the President and I and others couldn't
be more pleased with the absolute
unanimous support on a bipartisan basis
to get this done in regards to the
checks I announced yesterday from the
White House press conference first of
all most of these will be direct deposit
so we call them checks in the mail but
mostly we direct deposits it'll be
within three weeks we are determined to
get money in people's pocket immediately
so that will be within three weeks no
issues with the house we don't have to
worry about that meeting they hold it up
I would hope that the House passes this
unanimously I've already reached out to
the speaker and to Kevin McCarthy on the
sense of urgency the American workers
and American public and American
business they need the money now okay so
three weeks for most people now this is
really important to understand if you
don't have a bank account on file with
the government with the IRS from prior
tax returns you're likely looking at
three to five additional weeks meaning
it could be two months before you get
your check or direct deposit that's
going to be discussed that's a different
process that still has to be figured out
so the people in the three-week bracket
that Stephen minuchin is referring to
are people who file tax returns either
already for 2019 or you filed your 2018
taxes and you had a refund which
required you to or gave you the option
of putting in your bank account info so
that you got the refund via direct
deposit and that bank account is still
active if you meet that criteria you got
a refund in the last two years and the
bank account you used is still active
then you are in the three-week bracket
okay that's estimated to be half of the
people that are eligible for the checks
for the deposits the other 50% it's
going to be a much longer process and
they're looking at anywhere from three
to five additional weeks from what I've
been reading so far so consider the the
sort of conflict the how in Congress all
of these different things are Trump is
talking during his daily press briefings
like we've almost won the fight against
the so-called invisible enemy the
invisible scourge or scourge as he calls
it
he wants to open things back up on April
12th he wants church is packed for
Easter meanwhile in the best case if the
government has your Bank info on file
you will get your twelve hundred bucks
after Trump wants the country reopened
if they don't have your Bank info on
file you could be looking at three to
five more weeks now as far as if you're
not up to speed on the details
this is 1200 bucks per person for income
up to seventy five thousand it starts
phasing out between 75 and ninety nine
thousand dollars in income and then
after ninety nine thousand dollars it
goes to zero the numbers are doubled for
couples so if you have a couple the
ceiling is a hundred and forty nine K or
a-hunting 150,000 call it if one person
makes one hundred and forty eight
thousand the other person makes a
thousand as a couple you make 149 you're
still under 150 you still get twenty
four hundred dollars total twelve
hundred each you also get five hundred
dollars per child and then in addition
to this for folks who are filing for
unemployment benefits the federal
government from assuming that the house
signs this this is in the Senate bill
but we have to assume that the house was
gonna do the same thing the federal
government will boost state unemployment
benefits by six hundred dollars a week
that's huge there there are states I
know folks in some states in the Midwest
where the benefits are in the 300s per
week so if the benefits three call it
375 a week another six hundred a week is
literally the difference between being
able to afford your necessities and not
so that is a really big deal but again
notice nothing lines up we have an
incoherent timeline many governors are
extending stay home orders into April
some of them are even going into May
Trump says we're winning and we're
reopening on April 12th half of the
country is going to get checks around
April 16th the other half are looking at
mid May for getting their checks or
direct deposits and meanwhile cases and
deaths continue to explode faster and
faster in the US accelerating even
beyond the growth that Italy and Spain
saw at their worst moment so we're not
in good shape we're gonna deal later
today with the unemployment issue
we're going to deal with the case rate
and a whole bunch of other stuff despite
all of the bad news I am glad that
you're with us today let me know your
thoughts on what we've discussed so far
on Twitter I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
I've got something really cool today the
first 500 people who see this video and
go to david pakman.com slash skill will
get a premium membership to Skillshare
for two months for free skill shares the
online learning community offering
thousands of classes on almost anything
you can imagine
everything's taught by experts the
classes get split up into bite-size
lessons so even if you're really busy
like me you can fit Skillshare into your
schedule there are classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design running a small business and
that's not even scratching the surface I
got some great ideas from a recent class
I took called YouTube success and even
though we've been on YouTube for years I
still got a lot out of it they have
classes for every skill level whether
you want to get better at something
you're already experienced in or you
want to explore something totally new
and like I said the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two months giving you access to every
class Skillshare offers check it out I
put the link right underneath this video